>> Jason: WELCOME BACK TO THIS
"HANNITY" SPECIAL, TRUMP VERSUS
THE RESISTANCE.
TRUMP GAVE A PHONE INTERVIEW ON
FOX AND FRIENDS THIS MORNING
MORNING AND ONLY EXPRESS HIS
SUPPORT FOR A CHANCE TO DEFEND
HIMSELF AND ALSO NAMED
SEVERAL WITNESSES WHOM HE WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY.
LET'S WATCH.
>> THERE'S ONLY ONE PERSON I
WANT MORE THAN WHERE IS HUNTER,
AND THAT'S ADAM SCHIFF.
I WANT TO PUT THAT GUY WITH HIS
WAY.
>> WHAT YOUR FIRST QUESTION FOR
ADAM SCHIFF?
>> I ALMOST SAID SOMETHING THAT
MIGHT'VE BEEN SLIGHTLY
CONTROVERSIAL.
LOOK, I WANT TO SEE ADAM SCHIFF
TESTIFY ABOUT THE WHISTLE-BLOWER
WHO IS A FAKE WHISTLE-BLOWER.
BUT I WANT HE WANT THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER WHO PUT IN A
FALSE REPORT TO TESTIFY.
WHO I WANT TO TESTIFY MOST IS
SHIFTY SCHIFF AND I WANT TO KNOW
WHY HE MADE UP MY STATEMENT, HE
IS A CORRUPT POLITICIAN.
WHY DID HE MAKE UP MY STATEMENT?
>> Jason: GOOD QUESTION.
MEANWHILE, INDEPENDENTS ARE
SIRING ON THE IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRY.
ACCORDING TO AN NPR-MARIST POLL,
50% OF INDEPENDENTS DO NOT
SUPPORT IMPEACHMENT AND MOVING
TRUMP FROM OFFICE.
HOUSE FREEDOM CAUCUS CHAIR
CONGRESSMAN ANDY BIGGS, HOUSE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE OR
CONGRESSMAN TOM McCLINTOCK,
AND SENIOR ADVISOR TO THE TRUMP
2020 CAMPAIGN JENNA ELLIS.
I THINK ANDY, ALL THREE OF YOU,
BUT IN THE END, I SERVED WITH IN
CONGRESS PREVIOUSLY BUT I THINK
ALL THREE OF YOU FOR JOINING US.
I WANT TO START WITH YOU.
CONGRESSMAN McCLINTOCK, YOU
WERE ON THE HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AND IF THE DEMOCRATS,
AND I THINK THIS IS QUESTIONABLE
WHETHER OR NOT THEY MOVE
FORWARD, BUT IF THEY WERE TO
MOVE FORWARD, THE RULES ARE
DIFFERENT.
AND YOU GET TO CALL PEOPLE.
THE DEMOCRATS WILL GET TO CALL
PEOPLE.
WHO WOULD YOU LIKE TO HEAR COME
TESTIFY BEFORE THE HOUSE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE?
>> I'M HOPING WE COULD GET
VIKTOR SHOKIN.
HE'S THE UKRAINIAN PROSECUTOR
GENERAL THAT BIDEN HAD FIRED
JUST AS WE WERE LOOKING AT THE
CORRUPT RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
BIDEN'S SON AND BURISMA.
THAT IT BE A VERY INTERESTING
CONVERSATION TO HAVE.
OBVIOUSLY THE SO-CALLED
WHISTLE-BLOWER WHO CONCEALED HIS
RELATIONSHIP WITH ADAM SCHIFF
WOULD BE VERY INTERESTING TO
HEAR FROM.
I THINK THAT HE HAS TIES TO THE
WHOLE CABAL THAT DREAMED OF THIS
RUSSIA COLLUSION HOAX TO BEGIN
WITH.
THAT WOULD BE A VERY INTERESTING
CONVERSATION.
THE FACT IS SO FAR THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE -- WE'VE ONLY BEEN ABLE TO
HEAR FROM THEIR HANDPICKED
PREVENTIVE WITNESSES AND EVEN S
SO, THE AUDIENCES LEAVING THEM
AND THE REAL JURY, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE TURNING
AGAINST THEM WHEN THEY CAN CALL
DEFENSE WITNESSES, THAT WILL
SPELL DISASTER FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
>> Jason: JENNA, YOU'RE PART
OF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN, I
UNDERSTAND THAT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS INDICATION
OF WHAT'S GOING ON HERE, JERRY
NADLER BACK WELL BEFORE THIS
EVEN CAME UP, HE WAS PREACHING
AND SAYING THAT THERE WAS GOING
TO BE IMPEACHMENT IN JUDICIARY.
HOW DO YOU SEE AMERICA LOOKING
AT WHAT HAS TRANSPIRED OVER THE
LAST TWO WEEKS WITH THIS SCHIFF
SHOW.
>> AMERICA IS NOT BEING
BAMBOOZLED.
THEY SEE THE IMPEACHMENT CIRCUS
FOR WHAT IT IS AND THIS IS JUST
THE #Resistance THAT IS
UNDERMINING THE PRESIDENT AT
EVERY SINGLE TURN THEY POSSIBLY
CAN GET.
THIS IS THE NEXT LINE IN THE
HOAX OF TRYING TO GET HIM TO
REMOVE HIM FROM OFFICE IN THE
WAY THAT'S NOT AMERICAN, NOT
LEGAL, NOT CONSTITUTIONAL.
I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE
THAT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS TOTALLY
VINDICATED THROUGH THE
IMPEACHMENT HEARINGS THIS WEEK
BECAUSE WE JUST SAW SPECULATION
AND OPINION FROM THESE WITNESSES
WHO THINK THAT THEY CAN SET
FOREIGN POLICY AND THEY HAVE
BETTER OPINIONS THAN THE SITTING
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
THAT'S SHAMEFUL.
I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE
THROUGH THAT AND WE SEE THAT
EVEN A THIRD OF DEMOCRATS NOW
ARE SAYING THAT THEY WOULD LIKE
THE BIDENS TO BE INVESTIGATED
FOR POTENTIAL CORRUPTION.
THEY ARE SEEING THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS WORKING ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY SEE THAT HE LOVES THIS
COUNTRY.
I WAS SO PROUD OF HIM FOR WHAT
HE SET ON "FOX & FRIENDS" THIS
MORNING SAYING, BRING IT ON.
I WANT TO HEAR FROM ALL OF THESE
WITNESSES THAT WERE DENIED FROM
THE CHAIRMAN SCHIFF AND I THINK
THAT IF IT DOES PROCEED THE
SENATE TRIAL, WHICH IT
SHOULDN'T, THEY WOULD BE EVEN
MORE FULL EXONERATION.
>> Jason: CONGRESSMAN BIGS,
YOU ARE THEIR DAY IN AND DAY OUT
WITH YOUR COLLEAGUES.
BUT DO YOU REALLY THINK THAT
AFTER WHAT ADAM SCHIFF AND THE
SHOW THAT HE PUT ON, THE HOURS
AND HOURS OF TESTIMONY FROM
PEOPLE WHO HAVE NO DIRECT
RELATIONSHIP TO WHAT'S GOING ON
THERE, DID THEY MOVE ANY
REPUBLICANS OVER INTO THE
DEMOCRATIC CAMP TO VOTE FOR
IMPEACHMENT?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
IN FACT, I THINK WHAT HAPPENED
TO THEM THE LAST TWO WEEKS IS
THEY'VE ACTUALLY MOVE SOME
DEMOCRATS OVER TO VOTE AGAINST
IMPEACHMENT.
AND RIGHT NOW, IT'S GOING TO BE
NIP AND TUCK FOR THEM, IF
THEY'VE PUT IT ON THE FLOOR
WHETHER THEY GET THE NECESSARY
218 VOTES TO IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY HAVE REALLY BOTCHED THIS
THING UP BAD, JASON.
AND WHAT'S HAPPENING IS WHEN YOU
SEE THE INDEPENDENCE CRATERING
ON THIS ISSUE, IT MEANS THAT
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS ARE
GOING TO CRATER ON THIS ISSUE AS
WELL FOR THE DON'T WANT TO GET
HIM ELECTED BECAUSE THEY TAKE A
BAD VOTE ON IMPEACHMENT.
>> Jason: I THINK NANCY PELOSI
HAS HER HANDS FULL TO THE
NANCY PELOSI WILL POLL THIS AND
DO FOCUS GROUPS, GO LIKE THIS,
PUT HER FINGER TO THE WIND.